[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24
más Romero sala con nosotros en el
estudio mar el Día Mundial del apoyo
menitis es hoy que es lo básico que
tenemos que saber sobre esta enfermedad
Buenos días Raúl es una de las
enfermedades más dramáticas que ha
vivido la humanidad no recordemos miles
de niños sobre todo paralizados por esta
enfermedad por suerte gracias a
esfuerzos ingentes de la comunidad
internacional hoy en día está mucho más
controlada y estamos a un paso de la
erradicación es una enfermedad viral lo
provoca el poliovirus se transmite se
puede transmitir a veces por gotas de
saliva pero sobre todo es a través de
las heces de las personas infectadas que
puedan contaminar por ejemplo el agua o
por un mal lavado de las manos es como
se puede contaminar este contagiar este
virus el 75% de las infecciones son
asintomáticas es decir no dan ningún
síntoma de la mayoría de las personas
que sí son sintomáticas los síntomas
suelen ser una fiebre o un leve dolor
muscular nada que sea muy alarmante pero
en un 1% de los casos es cuando puede
llegar al sistema nervioso y así pues
provocar la parálisis por la que más se
conoce la la poliomielitis hay tres
tipos de polivirus o tipo 2 y tipo 3 se
radicaron ya en los salvajes digamos en
la transmisión de la naturaleza en
2015-2019 respectivamente sobre el tipo
1 del polivirus sigue transmitiendose de
esta forma natural Lo que sucede es que
una de las vacunas que se usan que es la
vacuna oral como hemos explicado otras
veces es un virus debilitado que si se
administra en comunidades con pocas
tasas de vacunación y se va también como
contagiando puede llegar a mutar
suficiente como para volver a ser
infeccioso y es por eso a este tipo de
virus que le llamamos virus pues
derivados de la vacuna puede encontrarse
este tipo dos o tipo 3 dónde estamos
ahora mar digamos En qué punto estamos
en el camino para finalmente Ojalá sea
pronto erradicarle apoyo estamos en un
lugar difícil no siempre se dice que la
última milla es la más difícil de para
correr y es lo que está sucediendo hoy
en día en lo que va de año de 2022 se
han de siglo 19 casos de poliovirus
salvaje y 223 derivados de la vacuna en
15 países distintos la mayoría países
africanos sin embargo no solo es
importante cuánto sino dónde esto ha
sido algo de lo más sorprendente que ha
pasado este año no tenemos casos además
de los países como Afganistán y Pakistán
donde el poliovirus tipo 1 es endémico
son los dos únicos países del Mundo
donde son endémicos en 2001 bon brote de
polivirus salvaje en malawi y mozambique
a pesar de que África se había declarado
libre de pollo en el año 2020 Aunque
fueron casos importados de Pakistán por
lo que es así que considerando que el
continente sigue libre de este virus
también además hubo brotes de polivirus
derivado de la vacuna en Israel en Nueva
York también no en Estados Unidos y en
Londres en Reino Unido también
relacionado con comunidades específicas
en las que las tasas de vacunación son
muy bajas es difícil que se generen
grandes brotes ahí pero no deja de ser
alarmante que está pasando y
definitivamente ha sido como un toque de
alarma para que vuelvan a estas
vacunaciones a sobre todo a los niños no
en en los que se interrumpieron bastante
por la pandemia de Kobe 19 claro estaba
polémica también como dices en esta
comunidad sobre todo en Nueva York las
judíos ortodoxa que no se quería vacunar
contra el apoyo pero vamos a los países
donde la situación es endémica Cuál es
la situación Precisamente en esos países
donde es endémica la enfermedad sí ha
sido una unos años duros no digamos que
en Afganistán por ejemplo la llegada de
los talibanes al poder suspendió las
campañas de vacunación masivas que se
hacen en el país además cuando los
talibanes ya habían estado Antes en el
poder no hay inicios del siglo XX habían
prohibido las campañas de inmunización
contra el apoyo en el país Entonces
digamos como mucho temor de que eso
volviera a suceder se han retomado las
campañas en retomado la vacunación
contra la polion Afganistán Pero eso no
significa que no sea un trabajo
peligroso De hecho hay trabajadores de
estas campañas que han fallecido en a su
trabajo por otro lado en Pakistán el
gran temor ahora mismo es el tema de las
inundaciones no el tema de la higiene de
tener agua saneada es básico para
combatir la polio y hoy en día con estas
inundaciones a millones de personas que
han quedado sin caso que beben así pues
agua que puede estar contaminada no hay
unas cifras todavía pero si hay el temor
rápidamente Mar no quiero dejarlo de un
lado tenemos noticias para celebrar hoy
el día mundial contra el apoyo sí
empezamos con lo malo vamos a terminar
con lo bueno a pesar de que han sido
años duros recordemos que los esfuerzos
para erradicar la polio empezaron en
1988 y desde entonces se han cumplido
muchos logros por ejemplo la incidencia
ha bajado en un
99,9% es una cifra increíble no
recordemos había centenares de miles de
casos al año en todo el mundo y ahora
apenas hay menos de mil que se detectan
cada año se han salvado 1,5 millones de
vida y se ha prevenido la parálisis en
16 millones de personas es decir tenemos
una vacuna que sirve administremos las
dos vacunas de hecho administrémoslas en
todo el mundo y celebremos pues que en
gran medida estamos muy cerca de nuestra
red dedicación de la enfermedad bueno
buena noticia para finalizar además
nuestro programa amar como siempre
Gracias por toda la información de salud
mañana con más Gracias a ti Raúl